[Musique]
après des mois d'attentes et beaucoup
d'incertitudes
elle est de retour à paris les clients
ont investi les tables des bars et
retrouver la fête de la musique place de
la république aussi plusieurs centaines
de jeunes se sont rassemblés devant des
tentes ou derrière cette camionnette
très vite stoppée par les policiers aux
alentours de minuit alors que les forces
de l'ordre évacuer la place
d'ailleurs avec la dispersion notamment
de gaz lacrymogènes jets de projectiles
il ya eu des débordements on s'y
attendait sans doute parce que cette
explosion de la fête de la musique a
donné lieu à ces débordements
bon c'est sûr on a lâché d'une certaine
façon les freins mais il ya encore des
règles sanitaires a observé sur la place
de l'hôtel de ville aussi plusieurs
centaines de jeunes réunis sans respect
des règles sanitaires
cette fois ci sur les champs elysées et
la question ici sous tension avec des
motards de la compagnie de sécurisation
et d'intervention de paris qui ont tenté
de disperser cette nuit les tout
derniers groupes de fêtards bienvenus
bienvenue à toutes et tous une ambiance
de fête qui détonne pour un lendemain de
défaite
veillez à ce que le maximum d'électrices
et d'électeurs se rendent aux urnes
c'est notre devoir collectif comme ce
taux d'abstention particulièrement élevé
nous interpelle à toutes et à tous
dire dire c'est la faute du gouvernement
c'est beaucoup trop facile macro il faut
qu'ils se posent beaucoup de questions
tous ces ministres sont sont pris une
baffe qu'ils doivent démissionner ou
bien si demandé lors d'événements mais
moi je pas demandé leur démission c'est
au président de la république à tirer
les conséquences de la légitimité de
ceux qui sont avec eux au gouvernement
il ne faut pas négliger ce que vous
représentez pour à la fois dans le rough
laetitia pour les militantes et les
militants qui l'ont accompagné le
sacrifice que ça représente
je salue son son retrait et j'imagine
aussi pour tout son camp sont équipés et
tous ceux qui le soutiennent la
tristesse de cette démarche mais ça
correspond à son engagement politique
depuis toujours c'est le mien d'ailleurs
est pas récent il est contre leur
assemblée nationale ça correspond il
n'était pas partant du tout des partis
il ya une chance de gagner
regardez ce qui s'est passé à perpignan
rien n'est joué
et si vous prenez
le temps de d'aller voter et bien vous
pouvez changer le sort de cette région
merci julien bayou et valérie pécresse
qui rentrait entre danseuses que
j'allais y céder votre place
voilà à partie un petit un petit chèque
qu'un petit chèque de 3 à 6 mois de
prison avec sursis ainsi qu'une relaxe
requis contre les treize cyber harceleur
2000 à cette jeune femme de 18 ans qui a
vivement critiqué l'islam dans des
vidéos sur les réseaux sociaux et qui
depuis vit sous protection policière
temps elle a reçu de menaces de mort
emmanuel macron qui prend même le temps
de poser avec la star canadienne justin
bieber en visite au palais c'est un
morceau d'histoire qui brille à nouveau
après 16 ans de sommeil 750 millions
d'euros d'investissements et des travaux
colossaux
la samaritaine renaît de ses cendres
câlins avec brigitte visite du palais
pose très inspiré devant un bureau car
on peut désormais y déjeuner où dormir
dans un hôtel de luxe
le bâtiment abrite aussi 96 logements
sociaux et une crèche
derrière cette façade moderne côté rue
de rivoli
après la collaboration avec mc fly et
carlito pourquoi pas un featuring du
président sur un album de bieber et
rihanna reçu elle en 2017
- emmanuel macron deux consulte sur un
futur remaniement ou non visages de lui
céder sa place
on se croirait dans une rave party avec
de dangereux de teufeurs